I was having lunch a while ago with some
friends of mine and my producer who's
been with me our executive producer now
like Thompson who's been with me for
almost 20 years and he said Dave you
know who one of the very first guests
you had on the air because you don't
have guests on the air very often still
when you certainly in the early days
never had them hardly who one of the
very first guests you had on the air
that was a big deal and I said who's
that he said the guy were eating lunch
with dr. Henry cloud who wrote the book
boundaries Henry's in town and so we
said hey dude come by hang out with us a
couple of segments because it's always
very popular to have you on the radio
and by the way if you're coming to
Dallas to our smart conference because
you want to be smart Henry's going to be
one of the people helping you do that so
very cool welcome back Henry
good to be here Dave actually don't
people come to the smart conference as
they are smart right you know it is
oxymoronic as well you kids like a
paradox the people that need to come
don't and the ones that don't need to
come to that's the way it works listen
hey I but if you are not smart and
you're out there and you're getting hit
by a lightning bolt today and you
realize I want to be smart it is good
good day to do that it'll start you on
your smart journey to wake up's mark up
dr. Henry cloud author of one of my
favorite books ever boundaries is going
to be speaking he's with us this hour
Andy Andrews one of the top speakers in
America today author in The New York
Times bestseller the travelers gift
Emerson egg rich probably the best voice
on marriage up there today author of the
book love and respect his daughter joy
will be joining him speaking and one of
my favorite parenting authors of all
time make Meeker author of strong father
strong daughters all of these people
with Rachael Cruz my daughter talking
legacy and me talking money in one room
the Verizon Theatre 7,000 people and for
one day from 9:00 in the morning until
about 6:00 or so that evening however it
works out five or six eight I don't know
what it is something like that anyway
you're going to leave there these are my
best some of my favorite people I
thought if I could have anybody and I
drew it up and then voila they were all
available by the way it's almost sold
out there's only about three four
hundred tickets left the tickets are
like $69 or they 69 or 79 79 69 69 good
I'm getting a clue from the booth
reading lips but
good and you can get that at Dave Ramsey
comm or call our customer care at triple
a 22-piece now enough of the tickets
welcome back to microphone Henry you're
going to talk on boundaries so we're
going to talk about boundaries and
specifically Dave about you know the
thing I like about the smart conferences
is about all of life you know it's not
just money and it's not just family it's
not just just marriage and in the way
that I believe success works in all
areas of life is those things are the
fruit of being in control of yourself
and the fruit of self-control ends up in
a lot of different arenas so we will be
talking about how to do that now
absolutely so one of the things that
happens when you get on this air here
and by the way if you want to talk to
Henry about boundaries you've got
boundary issues you think in your family
family members that are always asking
you for money family does that ever have
yeah kids that what kids that are 32 and
won't leave these kinds of boundary type
issues Henry's here and he can help you
to help them have some problems I told
that David story at lunch my I have two
daughters 11 and 13 and we were at
breakfast and I just asked him about
okay so what kind of guys do you want to
marry we're just having you know
breakfast conversation and my 11 year
old who at the time was nine she said
well I know what I don't want and I said
what's that listen she says I don't want
somebody's 40 and lives on his mother's
couch boom that's a dad going score
right that is gonna be okay this one's
gonna make it he's got some boundaries
so if you want to talk about that the
phone numbers triple eight eight two
five five two two five you no boundaries
when you first just hear the word kind
of hanging out there the way we're just
dropping it in this conversation it
sounds a little nebulous from a
standpoint of just personal
relationships and leadership and success
and money what's a good basic definition
of boundaries what are they why do we
need them well basically the basic
definition is the boundaries a property
line you know if you think of your home
or your apartment or your house there's
a property line that defines where you
end and someone else begins okay so once
you establish this is me and that's you
then we know some key elements of life
who's in control of what what we're not
in control of and also what we have to
be
responsible for and where boundaries get
screwed up is in families you've got a
lot of times one person that you see it
on the show all the time one person
that's out of control spending or out of
control irresponsible
but somehow the boundaries are unclear
so the responsibility of that and the
consequences of that are falling on the
wrong person the parent or the loved one
and yet they can't control that other
person's behavior and boundaries help
straighten all that out you know I
didn't even think of that that call I
got in the other hour was a boundary
call I believe I know it was in this
hour the lady that called and she and
her husband had co-signed for their sons
who student loans $100,000 and he's got
his degree in philosophy oh and so guess
what
he's waiting tables and she was the
wrong question I was trying to think
about how to be nice to her in kind to
her but her question was how are we
going to pay this back we yeah there was
the problem the pronoun yeah and so
there was the secret and so my advice
was for her to help him solve his career
crisis right that he has um but that's a
boundary thing really it says it is
about anything and you know there there
is a created order in life and and the
way that life is designed is that
someone should be responsible for what
they can control and someone else should
be responsible for what they can control
and it's things like our own feelings
our own attitudes our belief systems our
choices our behaviors I can only control
mine you can only control yours and when
we each take responsibility we have
something called relationship and love
and freedom and good things happen but
when those boundaries are crossed day
like co-signing okay I am going to take
the responsibility of a loan that you're
supposed to pay back right but I don't
have control of you if you're on the
couch you know you're playing what is a
game xbox Xbox game boy or something and
I can't control that so what do I do
what happens now I'm nagging now when
are you going to go work when are you
going to win - you're going to and I'm
trying to get somebody to do something
that they're in control of not doing now
we have a relationship problem so if we
get the boundary straight then we don't
have
it is referred to you know if you go way
back to the prophets where they say it's
trespassing to a trespassers when you
step in somebody else's yard in their
heart mind soul door body and you're not
an invited guest you're a trespasser and
all sorts of bad things happen even as
simple as getting in my personal space
that's right that's it there is a
personal space the book is called
boundaries I notice you were scooting
back there yeah well when to say yes how
to say no how to take control of your
life and it's the book that I've given
away literally thousands of copies of
here on the air the author dr. Henry
Cloud is with us and we're glad he's
here boundaries for your family for your
friends your spouse your children
boundaries and work boundaries for
yourself you've got a new book that's
doing very well called boundaries for
leaders that is their leaders yeah and
and what's weird is is that there's
leaders almost all around us we
sometimes don't think of mom with the
kids as a leader but she is well that is
exactly right and one of the things I
tried to do in the book is is look if
everybody whether it's mom trying to get
the kids in the band by eight o'clock to
go to school or somebody running a
company everybody is trying to do pretty
much the same thing you start with a
vision or desired result you engage the
talent to go do it you have a strategy
you execute that strategy you hold
people accountable and then you kind of
fix what you find along the way if
that's true if everybody's doing the
same thing why do some people get
results another stone and the answer a
lot of times is because some people are
leading people with the boundaries that
people's brains can follow and other
people are trying to lead people in
confusing those boundaries so nobody can
actually follow them and whether it's in
a family or a business there's a handful
of boundaries that are absolutely
essential for people's brains to get
results the book is called boundaries it
started the Henry cloud revolution and
it's morphed into boundaries for
teenagers boundaries for leaders it was
teenagers wasn't there but what's John
Townsend wrote boundaries for teens we
wrote boundaries for kit boundaries with
kids the boundaries for marriage and
boundaries for dating and now the
the the last one that idea was foundries
for leaders and then you've got
necessary endings which is a type of
setting boundaries without a doubt and
then we've got integrity all bestsellers
and you can check them out let me just
tell you if any cloud wrote it you
should read it I have and but if you're
going to start your journey on the Henry
cloud ship you need to start it with
boundaries and it'll lay the foundation
for you he's going to be speaking with
me and with all this other dream team at
the smart conference in Dallas and we
want you to come there's just a few
tickets left literally there's about
three four hundred something like that
this morning and it's almost sold out
it's going to be March the 29th and at
the Verizon Theatre which is very nice
about you and about 7,000 of your
closest friends will be there with Henry
Cloud Andy Andrews Emerson egg rich Meg
Meeker Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz Emerson's
daughter joy as well so we're gonna talk
about marriage we're going to talk about
money we're going to talk about
boundaries we're going to talk about
everything
you
you